and he's joining us right now uh here on
the rich eisen show he's justin herbert
of the
los angeles charges how are you justin
doing well thanks for having me uh
thanks for calling in greatly appreciate
it
um let's get to that i i'll start right
off the bat
uh because again a man who's follicly
challenged
obsessed with hair why why'd you cut
your hair justin the whole country was
talking about what happened there
it was time to switch it up you know uh
after going through a couple losses and
and things like that you know maybe
maybe we had to switch it up and okay um
was just it was just getting a little
too long so it was a team thing because
statistically you're
you're lighting it up you cut your hair
for the team it was a team thing
yeah when you say like that uh i like it
better that way okay even though there
is an eye in justin but not one in
herbert it was a team thing
now um i know john lott i know him uh
your strength and conditioning at coach
because
he was the one of the first uh coach
stars of nfl network we've
discovered his uh uh you know
his energy in the weight and reps room
at the combine he was the one who cut
your hair
correct uh simple question why
why would you let john lott cut your
hair uh that that is a great question he
said he could do it he said he's had
experience
um i trust the guy and um i wasn't
looking for anything pretty
uh so it did the job and uh you know
going forward i might look
um a little harder to find someone
cutting hair but uh it was good enough
for me okay you're in southern
california now justin
um there are many many people that would
do this job i think a little bit
um stylish than what john locke did
so do we call this the lot like sit down
in the chair and say give me the lot
is that what that is yeah it was
actually in the weight room um
it was pretty fitting come on now
in the weight room there's no i imagine
there are some mirrors i guess
yeah i think that's why we kind of did
it there there were enough mirrors so
um it gave us a good look and okay all
right um
last one for you on this justin uh what
did
uh your loved ones in your life think of
this
they supported it um my my hair is
normally pretty
short um it's only been the past couple
of years where it's kind of grown out so
i think people were kind of used to that
okay the people i knew but uh i i just
thought it was time you know
okay all right um and so your mom gave
it the thumbs up
she likes it yeah she she uh she
approved okay god bless
good for you man uh i just i'm i just
i only know one speed when it comes to
that so i guess i just wanted to
hit on that i've just what to what do
you attribute your success so far
justin in this league um i think a great
team and i think
a great coaching staff that has helped
me uh tremendously over the past couple
of weeks and
and uh from the off season until now i
think we've we've done a great job of
working footwork and
timing and um just timing with the
receivers and all these reps that we've
been able to get
um i think we've improved quite a bit
over the time okay and uh
throw some coaches names out there i i
would imagine coach hamilton would be
the first one you would throw out here
yep coach hamilton and coach stein as
well those two have been
uh huge in our development we've spent
so much time whether it's been on zoom
or in person
uh just getting better and talking about
film and um even in this off season
spent some time with coach hamilton uh
watching film uh
when when he was when he wasn't in the
building we weren't allowed to be
together
i just watched him film so i got some
time together that way watch some film
of what
uh game game game uh game film so
whether it was the bengals we
when we opened up with them or or the
chiefs or kind of going through our game
opponents like that
so um justin herbert here on the rich
eisen show let's go back to that chiefs
game i know you've talked about it in
other shows but this is the
first time that we've spoken since then
week two walk me through when you
learned you were starting against the
the chiefs justin it was right before
the kickoff
um well i think actually it might have
been right before we went out and
huddled so we get the kick off and i'm
i'm yelling let's go offense let's go
offense like i'm ready to cheer on the
team and
uh coach flynn comes up to me and says
justin you're in and uh i kind of looked
around
kind of surprised because i i really
wasn't expecting that um
and then coach hamilton coach steinkind
come right up to me and they're saying
like
it's time to go look you're going in and
wow this is really real and i went out
there and
um i think everyone in the huddle was
kind of surprised because they weren't
really expecting me to be out there
so you get out there in the huddle and
then the rest of the the the team is
kind of like
did anybody literally say what are you
doing here no no
a little funny at the time but uh no
they they kind of just said all right
all right
let's let's go and uh we went out there
and had a good drive
no because honestly i'm thinking about
things about my own career
literally john mcenroe once said that to
me in a tennis booth when i
called the tennis match he looked at me
and said what are you doing here when i
got to the booth and i know he was kind
of like busting my stones
so i was wondering if maybe something
like that happened with you too but
i'm also remembering the first sports
center i ever did um
justin when i was uh 26
um you know uh just on espn
out of literally uh a small market in in
reading california the reason why i
bring this up is it was march madness
and i had 13 highlights to do and i'd
only seen one of them before going down
to the
to the stage and i thought to myself i
have two choices i can literally either
pee down my leg i literally thought that
or just live for the moment that i've
been dreaming of my entire life
and i chose the latter because what else
are you going to do wow
i'm and i'm wondering if that was a
similar mindset you might have had
going out in that huddle i think so i
think that's a great way of looking at
it and
you know i've dreamed about this day and
and just being out there
and playing football in the nfl and when
they told me that i you know i had to
wipe a smile off my face and they're
like all right time to focus up justin
i just went out there and you know i had
fun and the best couple
couple of minutes of my life being told
that and yeah it's obviously a very
tough situation and tyrod has been so
supportive over over the past couple of
weeks and
um he's a great guy to have in the team
i was going to ask you about that justin
um about your relationship with him and
how he has helped you know i know you
mentioned your coaches how how he has
facilitated your ascension here yeah
he's the captain he's a leader of this
team and
a great guy to have in the locker room
and has been so supportive and when i
come off to the sideline he's always
there saying
you know they're doing this and doing
that and just kind of talking about what
we're doing offensively and
um whether it's in the film room or it's
out on the field um he's been great to
have
and and in retrospect um you know
getting your start like that obviously
i'm sure you dreamt your start would be
well coach names me starter i get full
week of practice or maybe a bye week or
something like that
the fact that you were in fact born into
this league
uh as a starting quarterback that way
means what do you think
to you i think it's a great opportunity
yeah
it would have been great to have a week
of practice and things like that um
but that's just kind of how things have
gone and it's always kind of been like
that where
you don't really expect it to happen and
you have to be ready
immediately and so you kind of have to
learn through it and live through it and
go through all these experiences
to become the quarterback that you want
to be what has been the hardest part
because to be honest with you i'm
sitting there
on my couch watching your games you make
it look simple
you really do oh i appreciate that i
think it's really tough when
um me being used to a college offense
where we didn't really go above a three
and a hitch drop
um sometimes i get too deep and the pass
rushers are a little different
at this level of the game and sometimes
i sit i sit back too much and
and you know the edge rushers just come
flying around and i get in some trouble
like that and so
just being able to step up in the pocket
feel the pocket um
and hang in there and make a throw is is
something i'm always going to be
learning
which edge rusher is giving you the most
crap though i
put you down and you got an exchange
from a veteran
um so far in your first nine starts uh
no mean words
um but i think brian burns from uh
when we played uh carolina um
he made some tough plays and and i think
i actually ended up fumbling one that he
hit me on and
um that was probably one of the learning
moments i had to go through the most
and in terms of just a few minutes left
here with justin herbert los angeles
chargers quarterback here i mean the
guys that you have had to face
off with again i know you're not on the
same field at the same time
with these guys but you know you
you you've gotten the homes in that
first game
for you then you've got brady then
you've got
i mean at any point in time did you sit
there and go oh my god
like you know like i know that you're
competing and you got to win here and
you you're bald out in in tampa but at
any point in time did you
stop and tell the 10 year old and
yourself what was going on at any point
in time
yeah that's a great question all the
time uh before the game when i'm out on
the field
you get to see those guys throw and warm
up and so i kind of watch them for a
little bit
and then even after the game you know
when you when you shake hands and just
say
you know good luck going forward and
just being able to talk to those guys
and watch them during the game
you get to pick up so much and uh and
keenan allen does he ask for the
football
uh or does he demand it at eight point
in time he's definitely a guy that uh
needs to be fed and boy did you feed him
last week what about that
yeah he's a special player and um i
think it's it's well known to get him
the ball and him and mike and hunter
uh especially anytime you can get them
the ball something special is going to
happen so
i know that it's my job to get those
guys the ball and so i'm gonna do my
best to
to get my job done and how has your life
changed in any way shape or form
over the last three months um i think
the biggest thing is no school
um i don't have to study and and prepare
for exams so it's all football and i
think that's the best part
uh what was the toughest class that you
took at oregon then i took organic
chemistry
um and that one took a lot of my time
and was definitely tough but but learned
a lot from it okay
uh how does organic chemistry help you
in uh the national football league
justin um i've yet to find how that the
two correlate
um today going forward it might pop up
so
i'll be better equipped you know i'm
just wondering like you know at some
point does the
does the periodic table or just knowing
that in any way shape or form help you
decipher a defense maybe i'm just trying
to
get the beautiful mind aspect of this i
hope i hope one day does because
um i know that i'll be better equipped
to it but i've yet to see it though okay
if we asked you what a certain number on
the periodic element
uh was right now would you be able to
regurgitate it would you be able to
throw that back at me
probably not unfortunately what was your
favorite element then you got a favorite
element
uh just carbon you know what it's
everywhere isn't it yeah you know what i
mean number six that's
six that's number six well he was the
sixth overall pick
he was the carbon kick in the 2020 draft
very good all right before i let you go
uh this is a question for me
i'm not gonna lie here how's austin
eckler doing
he's doing well um i've been able to
watch him kind of rehab and and he's
always in the training room getting
getting better so i know as soon as he's
able to go he's gonna be out there
because he's a fighter and
um you know i think he's posted a bunch
of videos of him squatting and running
and
he looks pretty good he's like he's
posting videos him running saying you
know thanks for people not dropping me
and was that 400 pounds he was squatting
was that literally 400
i think that's probably his warm-up set
come on really
he's uh yeah he's incredible in the
weight room okay so some people squat
400 in the weight room and others get
their hair cut in the weight room is
what you're telling me
yeah that's uh looking at it
oh my gosh justin uh i don't know again
you're not on
are are you you're not on twitter right
you're not out there on twitter no i'm
not
are you aware that that your haircut
sparked a whole thing
on social media of people posting their
haircuts that
uh are are shocking to others on twitter
have you
have you seen that david did you know
that no i think i've done a great job of
kind of staying away from that because
i think it gets it gets to be a pretty
negative place so um you know i've
stayed focused on football
well i think it's not negative to say
you look younger you look younger with
that haircut
i would love to look younger with a
haircut see these things are good
that's a compliment i'm serious you know
you there
thanks for the call justin i really
greatly appreciate it let's do this
again
uh more often i'm uh i'm uh very happy
for your success
and uh tell john lott that he should be
one and done as a barber
okay would you i don't know i'm sorry
i'm sorry stylist
use the word stylist will you please
gotcha okay thanks for the call justin
you take care thank you you got it
that's justin herbert everybody
usually i don't like to end interviews
with a joke that doesn't uh
land and say to the uh uh
guest you there you still there
[Music]
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here